sur les 20 villes les plus polluées de
la planète
dix sont ici en inde et ça ne va pas en
s'améliorant
aucun autre pays au monde même la chine
ne subit une telle pression sur son
environnement
l'air que l'on respire ici est tout
simplement le plus sale de la planète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce policier risque sa vie en travaillant
et ce petit garçon risque la sienne
enjoint le meeting des coupes livre de
rené lagacé est aussi ce qui nous plombe
la biotech skin probablement des
obstacles et les odeurs devant lens il
ya deux mois après le bois des coteaux
de la citadelle au 10e km et tibo'z à
marib est choqué les hôpitaux de new
delhi ont constaté une augmentation de
300% des consultations pour des
pathologies liées à la pollution ces
dernières années en fait aujourd'hui
plus de la moitié des indiens ont des
problèmes respiratoires plus ou moins
aigus les premiers touchés sont les
enfants et les personnes âgées
dans cette unité de pneumologie
on traite les patients victimes des
particules fines en suspension dans
l'air pour la première fois l'an dernier
le nombre d'indiens qui sont morts
prématurément à cause de la pollution a
dépassé celui de la chine il y a
maintenant plus d'un
chaque année qui meurent à cause de
l'air telle reste clair pour vous donner
une idée regardez la qualité de l'air à
montréal mardi elle était bonne et
maintenant celle au centre ville de new
delhi ces cinq fois pire l'inde est
encore fortement dépendante du charbon
pour produire son électricité dans la
banlieue de new delhi l'une des
centrales les plus polluantes vient
d'être autorisé à reprendre ses
activités
l'information donnée à la population est
aussi déficiente
beaucoup croient encore qu'un simple
tissu devant la bouche va les protéger
et ce pour leur art
je vais
les gravats la balle et c'est quand même
une sonnerie est plein l'autre livni ont
totalisé le gouvernement indien semble
commencer tout doucement à réagir
début avril il a interdit la circulation
de centaines de milliers de véhicules
qui roulaient avec le diesel le plus
polluant il y avait main endroits en
inde où les voitures électriques sont
obligatoires pas de véhicules à essence
à moins de 500 m du taj mahal
le célèbre monument et ses millions de
visiteurs chaque année des touristes qui
rêvent d'une photo dans l'alignement du
mausolée en marbre blanc
enfin plus si blanc que ça le taj mahal
est lui aussi victime de la pollution il
jaunit tout ça à cause du gaz carbonique
des pluies acides et de la combustion de
déchets kishore gupta est un guide
indépendant accrédité par le ministère
du tourisme
il a vu les changements de couleurs du
taj mahal depuis seize ans qu'il y
travaille tout lindberg
mais une autre menace plane sur le taj
mahal en plus de jaunir le monument
verdi la raison ce sont les crottes des
moustiques venue de la rivière à
proximité d'une rivière envahies par les
algues vertes du midem le courant de la
rivière vient tout droit de new delhi
250 km plus au nord avec l'air la
pollution de l'eau est un énorme
problème dans le pays
en inde le flash gates et tous les jours
[Musique]